getting my tires
happy
Wednesday everyone
happy Wednesday everyone especially
since we don't have many Wednesdays left
yeah it's that time again the end is
nigh all hope is lost
no Steve Ducey didn't get his own show
although Bill hemmer found out I've been
stealing his running shorts from the
break room
but forget about inflation or our
increasingly bellicose adversaries pay
no my defense and all the rising crime
rate or drag queen Story Hour
[Music]
that was a mistake
I'm talking about mother nature and boy
it's become a mother
of course this real threat to humanity
it's never really gone away it's
delivery day just keeps getting changed
the New York Times delivers this ominous
warning climate change is speeding
toward catastrophe the next decade is
crucial the UN panel says quote Earth is
likely to cross a critical threshold for
global warming within the next decade
the next decade the Nations will need to
make an immediate and drastic shift away
from fossil fuels to prevent the planet
from overheating dangerously beyond that
level
according to a major new report released
on Monday
a new report right huh it eerily sounds
like the same one Al Gore and the rest
of these lying fear-mongering
have been screaming at us for the last
40 years yeah
hey but so what right you peasants need
to suffer or the whole world will be
doomed
accepts that the times drops this not so
subtle caveat that contradicts the whole
report quote many scientists have uh you
know they've pointed out that surpassing
the 1.5 degree threshold will not mean
humanity is doomed
wait a second so wait we're not doomed
holy
why didn't you just say so to begin with
now I'm sure that this so-called
threshold is arbitrary just the thing
every fear Merchant can agree on it's
funny though the headline screams
catastrophe but then halfway through it
they say never mind
the shocking news isn't so shocking at
all imagine if that's how I called 9-1-1
huh hello everyone's gonna die why my
fan broke
foreign
what a bunch of shock blockers
anyway it's not as if there was any ever
any climate change before we all decided
we were killing the planet it's not like
12 000 years ago there was a giant
Glacier right where I'm sitting but no
one blamed that on one of my many yachts
but we've been down this road before
like every few years like for my entire
life and I'm 85 years old
I know I look great it's all about
hydration
and a healthy sex life isn't that right
Melinda
but these experts keep moving the goal
post because they're worse at predicting
the end of the world than the Mayans
2012 was the last time I donated a
charity because I thought the world was
ending what's the point huh kids are
gonna die they pick the year everything
ends and then that deadline passes then
coincidentally Greta thundberg deletes
her tweet about it and the climate
Crooks have to pick a new date and then
they start feeding for their doomsday
fix once again they say the sky is
falling when the only thing falling is
this guy on the stairs of Air Force One
ah
terrible but how often are we to keep
hearing this
the world is going to end in 12 years if
we don't address climate change
yeah right
if that's true why are you in such great
shape I mean if the world's ending
there's no need for a Beachbody hell I'd
blow up like Brian stelter and die on a
bed made of chocolate eclairs
but imagine if it wasn't climate
ideology being pushed but something just
as fallible like a Ponzi scheme but we
were forced to treat it with this solemn
respect Oh look The Bernie Madoff
Institute for financial wisdom has just
released its latest findings and yes you
need to give more money to the Bernie
Madoff Institute for financial wisdom
that's climate activism bottom line you
could never trust an addict even a
climate change one the apocalypse is
always around the corner then we turn
that corner and nothing so then it's the
next corner and the next they got more
corners than a haunted corn maze
and why because it's incentivized you do
this grift the world opens up to you you
don't get adolation if you speak soberly
on crime or nuclear energy climate's
different though Greta thundberg's
getting an honorary doctorate even
though she's literally famous for
skipping school
she's like Ferris Bueller but without
them but without the misfortune of
marrying Sarah Jessica Parker
but that's an incentive not just for
attention starved kids but for
attention-starved adults as well the
former teen will receive the award from
the faculty of theology at the
University of Helsinki she's the first
one to hold the title of doctor while
also needing one
but theology you know if I remember my
Greek and I remember a lot of Greeks
that's from the word Theo which means Dr
Cliff huxtable's only son
wait no Theo means god it's the study of
gods I wonder how many times my name
comes up in the textbooks right I mean
that I guess that means they're finally
admitting climate change is truly a
religion and it is just like Jonestown
[Applause]
as a divorced comedian he specializes in
disappointing kids and audiences after
her writer and comedian Jamie with that
oh
she came up with the idea to put Bank
pens on little chains most of the
evening added on Fox Business Liz
McDonald
[Music]
she's either itching for a fight or has
fleas the Fox News contributors
finally he has to crouch down to beat
his giraffe my massive sidekick in the
NWA World Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
Jamie obviously as we always point out
because I mean it's the only interesting
thing about you is that you live in
Alaska everything else is kind of boring
sad and tragic and a little bit
depressing so we try to focus on the
fact that you live you live in a state
far away that nobody really goes to and
it's super cold what are your thoughts
on climate change living in a place
that's literally freezing
yeah you said everything about my life
was sad and depressing and then added
that I lived in Alaska
like it didn't add to the whole yeah in
Alaska we're like less I will bring it
on it's freezing bring on the bring on
the increase in climate and some of this
makes me feel good like she said that
you know it could be they said it could
be the end of humanity yeah in five
years which makes me think oh my God I
saved exactly the right amount of money
for retirement
everybody's a sucker everybody who saved
got out you put on their money at the
end of the suckers right you won it
this Greta getting the honor isn't at
some point an honorary degree like a
slap in the face to people that got a
real degree absolutely there's a slab in
the back like it would be like can you
imagine if you were like at a restaurant
and then someone started choking and
someone was like oh my God is there a
doctor in the house and they go oh right
here and then you look up and it's Jill
Biden
and you're like
what what are you gonna do educate them
while they die yes
and by the way her uh her thing that you
were saying about skipping school yeah
that I believe is in reference to she
organized a Friday strike yeah her she
struck like they wouldn't go to class on
Fridays which if you're going to protest
in college it is smart to do something
that college kids like want to do anyway
like that's I did some stuff in college
it was real successful I did um sleep in
for sovereignty oh that's good on
Mondays and then I would bring all the
guys to ladies night and we would do try
to get a piece for peace
[Applause]
it was one of those trademark long Jamie
listow setups but I feel like I feel
like it worked out
Liz the difference in in like all these
kinds of activism is that in climate
activism there is an incentive to do it
even if it's wrong because of the amount
of exposure you get you don't get it
with anything else right yeah and I'm
hearing that like John Kerry and Al Gore
about to fly to Hawaii to talk about
this new report yeah you know you never
somebody made the point it's well it's
well taken that you can't disprove what
they're saying in real time so it's an
incentive to just to Ram through things
like what is Joe Biden going to do next
commandeer Tooth Fairy payouts and yeah
grocery store coupons along with 401ks
for climate change yeah what's in it was
Pete Buda judge gonna you know declare
the golden golden state bridge uh racist
I mean so what what are they going to do
next right so and it I think it's
interesting that we do it's interesting
to push back on what they're saying and
just really point out the climate
hypocrisy of like why can't they Zoom
why can't they Skype why do they have to
fly to the Bahamas to talk about this
latest if they are U.N report yeah we
have to be there in person because the
problem is so urgent we have to be there
in person right in my board shorts with
my SPF right you know eating a croissant
or a cheese danish or a daiquiri if you
will cat how you doing I'm okay all
right excellent good good good I'm glad
we got that out of the way so um are you
upset that cat no no cat agretta
easy to get us confused yes
she's got an honorary doctorate and you
don't yeah for her alarmism yeah and
like I also have alarmism not that like
the world's gonna be over for everyone
but that is just gonna be over for me
yeah my brain all the time is like this
is it for you and I believe it no matter
how many times it hasn't been like true
and I'm still here and everything's okay
yeah the difference is I acknowledge
that what I'm dealing with is mental
illness
I have a therapist I have a psychiatrist
it doesn't I I still believe that
sometimes but I think that they don't
acknowledge that they don't even
acknowledge that it might not be
effective after a while because one of
these days if the world actually is
about to explode or whatever nobody's
gonna believe it because they're like oh
the World's Gonna explode again and for
the normal well-adjusted people among us
after so many times it's proven wrong
then they're not going to really believe
it you know I I once created a story
about that called the boy you cried wolf
I don't know if you've ever heard of
that
wasn't there not a wolf there was never
a wolf yeah they ended up getting eaten
by like a like a gang of bears yeah not
before he was brutally sodomized
did I go too far there no great plot
twist well done thank you
so now that's the plot twist in all your
movies it always ends always ends that
way you know yes
I thought I thought there was like no
wolf and he died from climate change
yeah that's what it was did not see that
coming I have a question M night or yeah
enjoy to knock in the cabin you're about
to get a knock on the head
so what do you think do you think that
is there anything that deserves a panic
like this no well
I get the hustle I'm mad I didn't think
about it yeah you know you know like
with all the problems is going on we
have to fly to the Bahamas to get to the
bottom of it why are we sitting in this
we need to reconvene gutfeld's got to go
where do you want to go any place you
ever want to be oh anywhere Cayman
Islands are beautiful this time of year
we need to go down there and figure out
how to be funny yes yeah it's not enough
laughter in the world yes so here's
here's the thing folks there's been five
mass extinctions on this planet okay at
one time Antarctica was a beautiful
rainforest
well the rainforest wants its turn back
so
it's going to get hot somewhere else
cold somewhere else and the planet's
going to be fine yeah George Carlin said
it best it's going to be fine we might
not be around but the planet's gonna be
fine and there might be something new
yeah so you can't stop it but like when
you when it's a great point when you
create a puffy monster that you can
inflate and you keep going we've got
five years two years go by we've got
seven years yes I'm serious 12 years we
ruin her childhood but now she's a young
adult with a doctorate already I think
she's got a pretty good childhood yeah
yes so she's just gonna keep going yeah
well that was fun I'm very excited hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else